ya vimos una de las formas de la
ecuación de arrhenius que dice que la
constante de velocidad que es igual al
factor de frecuencia a por el elevada a
menos
sobre rt donde el a es la energía de
activación r es la constante de los
gases y t es la temperatura pero existen
otras formas de esta ecuación que
podemos usar dependiendo del problema
vamos a encontrar las empecemos
aplicando el logaritmo natural en ambos
lados de la ecuación y nos queda
logaritmo natural de k es igual a el
logaritmo natural de a por el elevada a
menos
a sobre r
ahora del lado izquierdo dejamos el
logaritmo natural de k
y del lado derecho podemos usar una de
las propiedades de los logaritmos el
logaritmo natural de a por el ala menos
a sobre rt es igual a logaritmo natural
de a más el logaritmo natural de e
elevada a menos
a sobre rt y el logaritmo natural de e
se cancele simplificando esta parte como
menos
sobre rt entonces nos queda logaritmo
natural de la constante de velocidad que
es igual a logaritmo natural de a menos
sobre arte pero vamos a reescribir lo
como logaritmo natural de k es igual a
menos
a sobre r por 1 sobre t más el logaritmo
natural de a lo escribí de esta manera
porque así es más fácil ver la forma de
la ecuación y es igual a mx b que es
igual a mx más b entonces si queremos
graficar el logaritmo natural de k lo
pondremos en el eje g y 1 sobre la
temperatura la pondremos en el eje x al
final nos quedará una línea recta cuya
pendiente es m que es igual a menos
an sobre r
así que podremos encontrar la energía de
activación a partir de la pendiente de
esa línea y si queremos encontrar el
factor de frecuencia sabemos que la
intersección de la línea en el eje que
es igual al logaritmo natural de a
entonces esta es otra forma de la
ecuación de arrhenius pero todavía
podemos encontrar otra empecemos con
esta ecuación que acabamos de obtener y
vamos a escribirla con una temperatura
específica para obtener una constante de
velocidad en particular digamos que el
logaritmo natural de k 1 esta es nuestra
constante de velocidad 1 es igual a
menos
a sobre r
por 1 sobre la temperatura de 1 observen
que con la temperatura 1 tenemos la
constante de velocidad uno más el
logaritmo natural de a
ahora usemos una temperatura diferente
de 2 entonces el logaritmo natural de k
2 es igual a menos
sobre r
1 sobre t 2 + logaritmo natural de a muy
bien ahora tenemos dos ecuaciones
diferentes para todos temperaturas
diferentes y dos constantes de velocidad
entonces el logaritmo natural de cátodos
menos el logaritmo natural de k-1 esto
es igual a vamos a ver el logaritmo
natural de k 2 corresponde a todo esto
entonces tenemos menos
/ r x 1 / t 2
es el logaritmo natural de a y a todo
esto le restamos el logaritmo natural de
cada uno que corresponde a todo esto
entonces nos queda menos y vamos a poner
todo entre paréntesis menos
/ r por 1 entre t 1 más logaritmo
natural de a ahora del lado izquierdo
podemos usar una propiedad de los
logaritmos el logaritmo natural de 14 -
el logaritmo natural de cada uno es
igual a logaritmo natural de k 2 entre k
1 y del lado derecho tenemos menos
sobre r por 1 sobre t
el logaritmo natural de a y después
tenemos dos signos negativos así que nos
queda más
sobre r por 1 sobre de 1 y luego tenemos
el logaritmo natural de a con signo
negativo entonces menos el logaritmo
natural de la observen que el logaritmo
natural de a se cancela y nos queda
logaritmo natural de cada dos entre cada
uno es igual a menos
a sobre ere que si lo factor izamos y a
sobre ere multiplica por 1 sobre de 2 -
1 sobre t 1
ahí está esta es otra forma de la
ecuación de arrhenius y la ventaja de
esta ecuación es que no tenemos el
factor de frecuencia
así que si conocemos las constantes de
velocidad a dos temperaturas diferentes
podemos encontrar la energía de
activación entonces estas son algunas
formas de la ecuación de arrhenius en el
siguiente vídeo veremos cómo podemos
usar cada una quizás se encuentren con
otras versiones en los libros pero
ustedes pueden usar la que más les guste